[Music]
guys
oh my goodness i don't believe you
no way oh my god you guys are gonna hate
this video
why yes okay there is this is it wendy
williams
oh no there's a tick tock that can tick
tackle
wait are you [ __ ] with me right now
we're doing another tick tock video
i told you all the news wants to report
is tick tock
i am excited i just thought she was
[ __ ] with me all day tick tock oh
yeah cause it's all about you day today
okay
no no i thought she was [ __ ] me i
thought she was [ __ ] with me too
though i didn't realize that but tiff's
not a [ __ ] around her that's true
i think tiff's fun you just don't know
when she's i think she's fun actually
you think she's boring i think she's fun
no she said she was boring
damn bart's messed up no i said she's
the [ __ ] around except sometimes you
don't know that she's doing it he says
that he doesn't know that she trolls
because she trolls seriously joe knows
his friend
steve well it's because when bart trolls
he's like he's like
i'm trolling
you're like okay i got it man yeah
if you didn't know nice and clear yes
okay
tick tock there is a there's a tick tock
of a pole vaulter oh i love pole
vaulting here we go
awesome baby you should try it nah
damn man how did they even have
something so large in their house
was close oh i thought it was going to
go in the [ __ ]
wait did he get [ __ ] nut checked by
the pole yeah do it again do it again
thumb
sometimes it's just oh that was a happy
ending though
i feel am i wrong well he made it yeah
yeah yeah
because it could have been he could have
just stayed up there the whole time
he hit his dick oh my god like one of
these oh showman
oh i thought he was going to land in his
[ __ ] and get stuck before
i thought oh it's pretty it's an
yeah holy [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah wow there's
impact there's definitely impact
that's one of the sports tiger can't
play cause he's a baby
no because because i don't think the
benefits
out outweigh the risk so even with
football
right like yeah you're gonna get hurt a
little bit but then you get mad groupies
and then you get a hell of money and
you're and you're looked at as like a
like american hero you get and then or
you see tte is one of the reasons or e
yeah a or e call to action hey guys
click
like the lebron james of pole vault yeah
we don't know his name you don't know
who the [ __ ]
he is no groupie [ __ ] pole vaulters you
don't know richard henderson like the
greatest [ __ ] pole vaulter of all
time yeah people don't even talk about
them anymore i don't think
they get groupies barely today i'm sure
there's pole vaulting
richard henderson had the greatest group
i don't buy it for a second
i think you were making that up oh she
is but it's only like the track
the track team groupies maybe it's like
they're hot though
at least they're goofy that's how i feel
about long jump nobody gives a [ __ ] that
you can long jump
what it looks sick as [ __ ] they put
their legs in front of their [ __ ] how
many long jumpers have you boned
thank you how many people have i boned a
period exactly but would you suck a long
jumper's dick probably not a long joke
for a long jumper stick yes
yeah no you sit there you open your
mouth and he jumps from eight feet away
yeah yeah
that's pretty sexy that would be pretty
cool see you you don't know what you're
talking about you're like
what's up can you reach this far okay
i'll try
every time jumps from the bathroom
[Music]
okay so this kid his name is zach and he
posted this on tick tock and so he
received
3.7 million likes and more than two 206
000 shares [ __ ] so it ended up happening
you'll get groupies from the tick tock
so this was back in this was filmed back
in september
during a practice and
during this practice you guys saw the
the pole ended up flicking his dick
no it ended up piercing his scrotum oh
so yeah jizz coming out everywhere
[ __ ] nut league do you know how this
works that's not how it works kids
what the [ __ ] it's like a ketchup
package i just saw you squeeze the
ketchup pack get this [ __ ] ketchup
flying everywhere
i just saw i just saw glaze
like donut glaze everywhere you catch a
packet inside of a bag and the bag
got torched yeah but it's blood not jizz
yeah yeah you know what i want to live
in your world
i want to live in bart's world his
[ __ ] jizz packets got punctured
so that means every time you get kicked
in the balls you can come a little bit
wow they're wearing the wrong shoelaces
oh his face
it's exactly it's like yep it was
punctured and then
he was with his dad this is a little
sister he was with his dad at
like his dad was filming and he's also
his coach and he's also the family of
pole vaulters
i guess and then but luckily that his
dad was there because he's also a
urologist
whoa what are the [ __ ] like this is
what happened
[ __ ] that's happened to bart's when he
farts
he was able to take them back to his
clinic office whatever and then gave him
uh sewed him up and with stitches but
what about the underwear
well they didn't sell it it was sold on
ebay for two years you can see the dry
blood on it too it's not so [ __ ] it's
blood
well it depends how you can puncture it
oh so they went straight to his office
and he got stitched
that's crazy they should [ __ ] frame
that picture that's still that's
a gas picture dad's like it's okay i
mean you're all it is
that [ __ ] looks like it's around here uh
no that's in utah
that's how boring california is it looks
like [ __ ] everywhere
we have the same mountains a dry ass
mountain yeah
it does like that you see a valley in a
dry-ass mountain you go that looks like
california
but yeah luckily he's okay and luckily
he got stitched up
real quick i feel like frank yang you
know the the crazy guy
the the fitness guy he would have stuck
a dildo at the end of it
and [ __ ] try to actually get it
scraping his ass yeah that's on purpose
probably a lot smarter and softer that's
more views on tick tock too
yeah more views on tick tock that's the
thing so a pole vaulter has to watch
this like maybe another pole vaulter
who's doing like
his clearing [ __ ] and posting it and not
really getting a lot of traction
and they see this and they're like all
right i gotta try to hit my nuts or
something
yeah so yeah you're sticking your butt
no i'm saying i'm saying that the next
this is inspiring other pole vaulters to
achieve less yeah
if they want to be tick-tock pole
vaulter or famous yeah you know what i'm
saying
i mean while you're up there just hit
that you can't just do what everyone
expects
you gotta [ __ ] clear i think they
have purists there that are like
pure pole vaulters and then they're like
these guys are [ __ ] up the game
hell yeah i'm sure in an accident it's
not even his fault yeah there's a bunch
of pole vaulters who are
who have their little enclave pole
vaulters right and they're like yeah we
do pole vault and right and like the
famous pole vaulters they're they do it
all
yeah they're like we're the real ones
but these guys they're all [ __ ]
sellouts yeah they sold out
we're really pole vaulted over here bro
you see i do it like this
they do it like this yeah but this is
the old school way of doing it like this
the real way yeah we don't get to go to
the olympics and [ __ ] but like at least
we're doing it real
we're doing it traditional the way that
it was meant to be
i've always wanted to try pole vaulting
why it's fun why
you get to fly like you just i don't
know it looks cool i wonder how you
start though do you start like
at head level because that [ __ ] is high
as [ __ ] that's just like a [ __ ]
on top of a hole yeah or is it or do you
start at like knee level and
run with little things i hope you start
that high and what's day one of pole
vaulting class are you just like
[ __ ] yeah right how do i do this [ __ ] no
there's no like thingy and then you just
do it and see how
and it's one of the most useless
athletic endeavors
because if you're a long jumper right if
you're like climbing mountains and [ __ ]
you're like you see a canyon oh long
jump that [ __ ]
or if you're a sprinter you could run
from like a cheetah this thing you're
like
yeah the same thing with the cannon you
have a stick yeah you're gonna need a
special stick you can't just find any
stick in there
take out your backpack and go no but you
also need that landing pad thing the
[ __ ] thing that it hits
and then you need a pad to land on
[ __ ] pointless
i'd rather be a javelin thrower we're
all gonna be running away from bad guys
and they're gonna a paul vaulter is
gonna grab a [ __ ] stick and go
ah [ __ ] you yeah where did he go he's
gonna need a special stick
it's not gonna be a [ __ ] electric
fence that we gotta get over to get away
from the bad guys and there's gonna be
electric fence and like
fluffy bushes and we're going to have no
idea how to get over it this guy's going
to be like
no what'll really happen is he'll be
like oh i can't do it i don't have my
crash pad no the fluffy bushes fluffy
bushes dude
yeah but i think the pole vaulter is
very he's he's very curious
i can't work under these conditions yeah
i'm not doing it with my craft right now
i'm not doing it i don't have my
sleeveless nylon shirt i can't jump this
thing you're mostly useless
dude it must be it must feel crazy
though going up and like feeling like
you're kind of flying
and then you fall back down like that
what about croquet isn't cocaine kind of
stupid it's a flat oh yeah i was gonna i
thought you're saying cookies better
than pork
what about the one in the olympics where
it's that ball on ice and they're just
oh curling they're just [ __ ] sweeping
the ice but it's sick looking
for you never watched curling all the
all the maids are at home like
they're actually like finger banging are
like whoa
endurance wrist endurance there are some
chicks who love finger bringing out
there
i don't know any but they are out there
i know they're out there well your wife
is definitely not not one of them
wait five of them in a row what was the
statement my wife does not like
finger-banging
oh really at all no not into it
it's not because of me that's what i
heard well look at your [ __ ] hands
i'm pretty sure it's only because of you
no it's not because of me that's what i
heard
[Laughter]
no i i knew a girl one time that when
she said she was messing with a guy
whoever tried to figure out she'd be
like she's like no
i mean she prefer the [ __ ] stimulation
rather than the fingers in her you know
i've heard the same still fingers that's
fine that's not finger banging yeah
but for nicki is like don't ever like oh
don't even touch my cooch
don't put the finger inside interesting
i can't put my dick in it either
damn so what do you do
yeah sorry that's solid yeah it's pretty
fun we have a good time yeah
right before he's about to dock he could
only put the tip pressed against it
yeah she's like oh i'm not into that i'm
like all right i respect that anyway
back to this kid so he's saying
that as far as he knows oh by the way it
was 18 stitches
that he needed to get and he said that
you could see right into his scrotum
yeah you could see like the balls like
hanging he's gonna have a weird scar on
his nuts
well yeah he just says that as far as he
knows there's nothing wrong with his
testicles that he just has a scar and
that he will find out later on when he's
trying to have kids whether or not well
he has the right dad
doctor to yeah good thing nuts already
look like they're scarred
i know right that's a lucky spot you
can't make
nuts uglier than the way that they are
already i mean they're already ugly god
made them as ugly as possible
they are and it's and you guys are
literally born that way yeah like it's
crazy like i thought they aged
like they wrinkled over time they
already look like 72.
yeah i'm like damn why do they look like
what dope is every time a girl [ __ ]
like
licks his nuts she's gonna have a cool
ass story she's gonna be like not really
well yeah because he's she's gonna like
hesitate she's gonna be licking go wait
yours has different texture yeah right
she's like oh i thought this was just a
nut wrinkle but it's actually kind of
like a scab yeah and he's gonna be like
well let me tell you about the time
she's like when i was politically she's
like
that's not a sport yeah that's the most
useless [ __ ] ever i just like throw this
dick to the side
thank you for watching that video we
thought it was hilarious that we said
that
pole vaulting is not a sport so we
turned it into a t-shirt
if you like this t-shirt make sure you
go to our store right below we just
opened a jk news merch store
and you can grab yourself this t-shirt
thank you i'll see you guys next time
bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you